this week Prince Harry launched a savage
attack on the press for bullying Megan
and announced he's suing a newspaper for
printing a private letter to her dad
this is an ill-timed ill-judged mistake
not least because their africa tour was
a triumph and for their critics me being
one of them it reminded us just what an
asset they can be look I get why how he
wants to protect his wife but it's
disingenuous and wrong to say that what
happened to his mum is now happening to
Megan it's not diana was hounded
unmercifully by the media I know I was
there but that's not what's happening to
Megan she and Harry are shielded and
protected precisely because of what
happened to Diana yes they've rightly
been accused of hypocrisy on climate
change they use of public money and
their demands for privacy but that's not
bullying that's being called out and
challenged and if they weighed in to
controversial issues then they must
expect that from the media not falling
sick of fencing the tragedy here that
Africa - er had restored their damage to
reputation now all the great stuff they
did will be destroyed in the war Harry
just declared on the press we've seen
the attitude the media has had two wars
Megan especially since their marriage
we've seen the racist conspiracies that
come at her left right and centre we've
seen that there was a couple about right
last year the BBC did an article on the
fact that she opened her own car door
the extent to which she is hounded by
the press cannot be understated so I
think for somebody who lost his mother
due to that I think it's totally
understandable they he would be upset
well let me first ask so you're saying
that everything that's been leveled at
Megan this week is about racism what is
this you just said a racist conspiracy
what is that what are you talking about
well as in people were suggesting but
fake pregnancy people have tweeted
that's not in the post was forced to
issue in 2016 because Twitter
when talking about the racial overtones
of the level of abuse she was getting
and Prince Harry himself who I have to
say if anyone knows about press hounding
the Royals he should know right so I
trust what he says but just to finish
he's talked to he's talked as well about
unconscious bias that affects the way
people talk about Megyn that people
don't really understand why they're
saying what they're saying so he's
somebody who's referenced this as well I
think it would be really weird not to
acknowledge that there is a racial tone
to the abuse okay so I think that's and
I think you can't apply any racist
accusations against the criticism
they've had over climate change are you
saying it's because she's mixed race
they've criticized what her and how
you've said over climate change about
their their their moaning about privacy
about their attitude to the public in
this country can I just make one point
here we just ought to be clear the press
did not kill Princess Diana she was in
an underpass being driven in a car by a
drunk if he was a big drunk that's why
Princess Diana died and she didn't have
her seat belt on in the car either so I
think we ought to divorce the idea that
the press killed Princess Diana
now the criticism the press have got
here about the Dutchess of Sussex no the
Duchess of Sussex is we hardly ever see
her we hardly ever see her we only saw
Artie the little boy for the first time
in Africa and as for the letter which is
the nub of the writ against the mail on
Sunday that was a private letter she
sent to her father he gave that to the
man on Sunday he didn't sell it to them
they didn't steal it from if they didn't
pry it out of his hands and he gave it
to them because they'd been a really
destructive article about him in People
magazine in the United States and who
put it there
three of Megan Markos friends you can't
have it both ways for me Nick I think
we're running two or three horses here
there has been a racial aspect but
honestly I don't think that's the press
I think that's where you look at some
horrific trolling that has gone on I
think now if you recall how the media as
a whole celebrated that wedding just
over a year ago so I would suggest that
the ugly and end of
one you cannot let lay at the door of
the media or the press also it's not the
presses fault that sadly the duchess
megan has a fractured relationship with
her father again the newspapers are not
to blame for that where I do have some
sympathy is obviously as you said Cal
Harry is acting as any husband would
because he won't put up with it and I
would say this I do think an unnecessary
caustic tone did start to get injected
in towards treatment of the Duchess and
with Harry as Andrew rightly said we can
all remember the horrific events of how
his mother died I think he was 12 at the
time he has an extraordinary place in
the heart of this nation because we
watched him as a little boy I think
because Megan and Harry seem to have
taken it upon themselves to handle their
own PR it's been catastrophic you know
we heard that they had a new fancy pants
PR organization but today we read that
actually they had nothing to do that how
he didn't tell them he didn't tell his
dad he didn't have a queen
he didn't tell wills now if you know if
you remember a few because they would
have said absolutely I remember a few
years ago when we'll sued over those
topless pictures of Kate absolutely
justified in suing the press on that
this is not justified I just want to
read out some of the headlines that
we've seen about Megan DeMarco recently
and by the way the palace in 2016 they
referred to the racial / undertones of
comment pieces is actually the media but
looking at the headlines we have Megan
Markham owns about life in the public
eye
Megan Markel is the worst kind of snob
Megan is accused of looking childish you
know these are not these are not
headlines that suggest a kind of neutral
observation about her and when it's one
after the other when it's constant as it
has been it's hardly a surprise they are
taking this the criticism they've had
Rachel has been over hypocrisy it's not
been over race or anything else it's the
hypocrisy on their on preaching to the
rest of us about climate change saying
every carbon footprint counts and then
taking four planes in the space of a
month it's their hypocrisy I'm talking
about poverty and then
having 300 grand parties in America
taking George Clooney's jet to get there
it's hypocrisy that is great it was
people may be helpful if we actually
just tell some viewers a little because
they might not be across fully what
Prince Harry has said so this is what he
said in that letter my wife has become
one of the latest victims of a British
tabloid press that wages campaigns
against individuals with no thought to
the consequences a ruthless campaign
that has escalated over the past year my
deepest fear is history repeating itself
I've seen what happens when someone I
love is commoditized to the point that
they are no longer treated or seen as a
real person I lost my mother and now I
watch my wife falling victim to the same
powerful forces to which the Mail on
Sunday the newspaper that published this
letter responds Ameland sunday stands by
the story it published and we defending
this case vigorously specifically we
categorically deny the Duchess's letter
was edited in any way that changed its
meaning that's one of his central claims
I suppose the thing that really this is
the idea that Megan is being happened as
she's been afforded more protection than
almost any role that I can remember
because of Diana this is 11 who was a
royal biographer had to say on this it's
a stunning that it's now at the end of
what has been an incredibly successful
tour when the press has been very kind
very positive they followed everything
they wanted from Megan going to
commemorate a young woman who was
murdered climate change all sorts of
things and cooing over baby Archie which
is all lovely and then to sort of take
the focus totally away from what's been
very successful he's very straight and I
think this is part of the problem for
them they're not listening to the people
around them I think I didn't do not
recognize the description of Harry as
painting in that letter he gave no
examples in that very long statement of
this daily harassment and pursuit of his
wife you know if the prince was gonna
set foot in this street
she was descended on by photography and
that stop and we were there you know we
I was around for that I was a royal
reporter that I saw how she was hounded
and she was but Diane and I hand
the press very cleverly and very well
she used the present exactly the same
way as we used to and I'm sure you've
read examples of that today in the paper
and that's that's what worries me Harry
is I think I think him and Megan are
just deciding what to do by themselves
and everything they've done so far has
been a PR disaster three little press
beasts here again I don't think we're
going to agree on that